bienvenidos de vuelta en este vídeo
quiero hacer un problema que nos sirva
de repaso de todos los conceptos que
hemos visto de probabilidad y algunos de
probabilidad condicional entonces bien
supongamos que tengo la siguiente
situación tengo una bolsa y en esa bolsa
tengo cinco monedas justas cinco monedas
justas
gustas que recuerden una moneda justa
tiene 50% de probabilidad de salir
águila y 50% de salir sol y además de
estas cinco monedas justas voy a suponer
que tengo 10 monedas injustas monedas
y justas
y que sería una moneda injusta pues una
moneda que tiene distintas
probabilidades de caer águila y oca del
sol por ejemplo vamos a suponer que
estos tienen un 80 por ciento de
probabilidad de caer águila
y un 20 por ciento de probabilidad de
caer sol
y bueno la situación va a ser la
siguiente yo voy a meter mi mano a esta
bolsa con 15 monedas y voy a sacar una
moneda aleatoriamente después me voy a
echar 6 volados y de esos volados voy a
suponer que 4 4 de 6
fueron águilas
fueron águilas en mis volados
y entonces me pregunto bueno ya que sé
que cuatro de seis de mis volados fueron
águilas cuál es la probabilidad de que
escogí una moneda justa escoger
moneda justa
dado que saque 4 de 6
águilas en una serie de volados eso es
lo que quiero encontrar y bien para
hacer lo vamos a recordar brevemente el
teorema de beuys
teorema de beige en probabilidad
condicional
veis se escribe valles pero como esta
era una persona inglesa tomás veis
entonces se pronuncia veis quizás
también lo conocen como el teorema de
valles pero bueno lo que nos dice es que
la probabilidad de que suceda un evento
y un evento ve esto es normalmente la
intersección en conjuntos entre
conjuntos pero lo vamos a considerar
como a y b esto va a ser igual por un
lado va a ser la probabilidad de ha dado
b por la probabilidad de b pero eso
también va a ser igual
también va a ser igual a la probabilidad
de b dado a por la probabilidad de ar
si esto no le suena familiar les
recomiendo que le echen otro vistazo a
los vídeos en probabilidad condicional
pero bueno ya en estas ecuaciones
digamos de ésta
de esta yo podría dividir todo entre la
probabilidad de ve y decir que la
probabilidad de a lado b es igual a la
probabilidad de b dado a por la
probabilidad de a dividido entre la
probabilidad de b
así que esto nos puede ayudar a
encontrar está probabilidad en este caso
en este caso
a sería escoger
escoger
moneda justa
nada justa
y ve sería
sacar
4 de 6
águilas
es decir en una serie de seis volados
sacar cuatro águilas exactamente
entonces vamos a utilizar esta fórmula
de aquí está para tratar de encontrar la
probabilidad que buscamos la parte más
complicada va a ser encontrar la
probabilidad de be que sería la
probabilidad en general de sacar cuatro
de seis águilas con cualquiera de las
monedas en la bolsa y quizás estos dos
no salgan de pilón por el camino bien
entonces para encontrar la probabilidad
total o general de sacar cuatro de seis
águilas en una serie de volados vamos a
considerar qué pasa cuando apenas meto
mi mano en la bolsa pues al meter mi
mano en la bolsa y sacar una moneda
pueden pasar dos cosas o saco una moneda
justa digamos que moneda justa qué
porcentaje de probabilidad tendría pues
si hay cinco monedas justas y hay quince
monedas en total entonces tengo cinco
entre 15 de probabilidad de sacar una
moneda justa 5 entre 15 es simplemente
un tercio o también podría sacar una
moneda injusta y cuál es la probabilidad
de que saque una moneda injusta pues
ahora tengo 10 monedas injustas entre 15
monedas en total sería 10 entre 15 que
es dos tercios
ok entonces supongamos que saque una
moneda justa ya que hice eso cuál es la
probabilidad de que con esa moneda saque
cuatro de seis águilas pues consideremos
un evento arbitrario en el que sacó
cuatro de seis águilas podría hacer algo
así como águila sol águila águila sol
águila o algo como sol águila águila
águila sol águila y cuál es la
probabilidad de algunos de estos eventos
cualquiera
pues sería un medio de probabilidad de
sacar sol en el 1er volado por un medio
de probabilidad de sacar águila en el
segundo por un medio del tercero por un
medio del cuarto quinto y sexto es decir
la probabilidad de un evento cualquiera
en el que sacó cuatro águilas
exactamente sería uno entre dos a las
seis y esta es la probabilidad para
cualquiera de los eventos en los que
sacó cuatro de seis águilas también para
este porque en todos simplemente es un
medio por un medio por un medio por un
medio por un medio por un medio uno
entre dos a las seis
y cuantos de estos eventos tengo
digamos que de nuevo soy el dios de la
probabilidad entonces lo que tengo que
hacer es elegir cuatro de los volados
para que salgan águilas y la forma de
considerar eso es como ya hemos visto
considerar el coeficiente binomial de
seis en cuatro o las combinaciones de
seis elementos tomados de cuatro en
cuatro así que tengo esta cantidad de
formas de sacar exactamente cuatro
águilas multiplicadas por la
probabilidad de sacar águila en cada una
de ellas cuatro águilas en cada una de
ellas que es uno entre dos a las seis y
este número con tres el coeficiente
binomial de seis en cuatro es seis
factorial entre cuatro factorial por
seis menos dos factoriales es decir dos
factorial y todo esto por uno entre dos
a las seis
y esto cuánto es pues 6 factoriales 6
por 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
4 factorial va a ser 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
por 2 factorial que va a ser 2 por 1 y
todo eso por 1 entre 2 a la sexta que es
uno entre 64 ok vamos a cambiar de color
para que no sea muy monótono esto cuánto
es esto pues este 4 3 2 1 cancela este 4
por 3 por 2 por 1
este 2 lo puedo cancelar con este 6
convertir el 6 en un 3 este 1 lo puede
ignorar y me queda 3 por 5 que es 15
por 1 entre 64 o lo que es lo mismo 15
entre 64 y esto va a ser la probabilidad
de que con una moneda justa haya sacado
exactamente 4 águilas es decir esto es
la probabilidad de sacar cuatro de seis
águilas dado que tengo una moneda justa
es decir esto es la probabilidad de b
dado a pero todo esto fue con la
suposición de que sacaba una moneda
justa que hay si saco una moneda injusta
entonces vamos a ver un evento
arbitrario vamos a usar este nuevo sería
algo en la forma son águila águila
águila sol águila y cuál es la
probabilidad de este evento cuál es esta
probabilidad pues ahora tengo 0.8 de
probabilidad de sacar águila y 0.2 de
sacar sol así que esta probabilidad
sería 0.2 de sacar sólo en el primero
por 0.8 de sacar águila en el segundo
por 0.8 de sacar águila en el tercero
punto 8 de sacar águila en el cuarto por
0.2 de sacar águila perdón sólo en el
quinto volado por 0.8 de sacar águila en
el sexto volado así que esto sería 0.8 a
la cuarta
por 0.2 al cuadrado y este número es
independiente del orden en el que me
salgan las águilas y los soles lo que
importa es que me salen exactamente
cuatro águilas así que esa es la
probabilidad de cada uno de estos
eventos y cuántos de estos eventos tengo
pues de nuevo tendría seis en cuatro las
combinaciones de seis en cuatro así que
la probabilidad de sacar exactamente
cuatro águilas con una moneda injusta
sería las combinaciones de seis en
cuatro las maneras de elegir cuatro
elementos de entre seis por la
probabilidad de cada uno que es 0.8 a la
cuarta por 0.2 al cuadrado y esto es 6
en 4 ya habíamos visto que era 15 así
que esto es 15 por 0.8 a la cuarta
por 0.2 al cuadrado y esto de aquí ahora
es la probabilidad de que saque 4 de 6
águilas la probabilidad de b ya no con
una moneda justa sino con una moneda
injusta dado que tome una moneda injusta
bien ahora cuál es la probabilidad total
de sacar exactamente 4 águilas
pues va a ser precisamente la suma de la
probabilidad de que escogió una moneda
justa por la probabilidad de sacar
cuatro águilas con la moneda justa más
la probabilidad de haber sacado una
moneda injusta por la probabilidad de
sacar exactamente cuatro águilas con la
moneda injusta es decir va a ser un
tercio un tercio que es la probabilidad
de sacar una moneda justa por la
probabilidad de sacar cuatro águilas con
una moneda justa que es precisamente
esta de aquí entonces va a ser un tercio
por 15 entre 64 más la probabilidad de
sacar una moneda injusta dos tercios por
la probabilidad de sacar cuatro águilas
con la mano injusta qué es esto de aquí
es decir por
por 15 por 0.8 a la cuarta por 0.2 al
cuadrado y esto cuanto después si
simplificó esto lo podría escribir como
15 entre 3 55 entre 64 más 15 entre 3 de
9 5 5 por 2 es 10
por 0.8 a la cuarta por 0.2 al cuadrado
y déjenme saco mi calculadora
bien entonces esto va a ser 5 entre 64 +
10 por 0.8 a la cuarta por 0.2
al cuadrado si esto es 0.24 19 que y
entonces todo esto me daba 0.24 19 y
había un 65 por ahí al final o escrito
como un porcentaje esto es el 24 punto
19 65% de los casos de modo que esto de
aquí es precisamente la probabilidad de
obtener exactamente cuatro de seis
águilas es decir la probabilidad de de
nuestra anotación muy bien y con esto ya
estamos listos para resolver el problema
déjenme copias de aquí esta formulita
que deducimos del teorema y vice copio
y la pego por acá abajo
pegarla aquí
y déjenme la traduzco recuerden esto es
lo que me está diciendo es
la probabilidad de a era escoger una
moneda justa
dado que saque cuatro de seis águilas
cuatro de seis águilas en una serie de
volados el teorema vice me dice que esto
va a ser igual a la probabilidad de
sacar cuatro de seis águilas
dado que tengo una moneda justa
por la probabilidad de sacar una manera
justa
/ /
la probabilidad de sacar cuatro de seis
águilas en general así que bien vamos a
sustituir todo lo que hemos encontrado
primero que nada cuál es la probabilidad
de sacar cuatro de seis águilas dado que
tengo una moneda justa pues la tengo
aquí precisamente es 15 entre 64
así que esto va a ser igual a 15 / 64
por la probabilidad de sacar una moneda
justa la probabilidad de sacar una
moneda justa era precisamente un tercio
por un tercio dividido entre la
probabilidad de sacar cuatro de seis
águilas en general que la encontramos
ahorita y fue 0.24 1965 y cuánto es esto
déjenme vuelva a sacar mi calculadora
15 / 64 por un tercio eso lo pude haber
hecho a mano pero bueno y voy a dividir
entre 0.24 1965
y eso me da 0.32 28 0.32 3 vamos a decir
así que esto vale 0.32 3 o lo que es lo
mismo
el 32.3 por ciento de los casos pero
bueno esto es bastante interesante
porque la probabilidad de haber elegido
una moneda justa era de el de 1 entre 3
que es el 33.3 por ciento así que en el
momento en el que yo saco cuatro de seis
águilas que son más águilas que soles
automáticamente lo que me dice eso es
que es más probable que haya sacado la
moneda injusta porque la moneda injusta
me da mayor posibilidades de sacar un
águila y déjenme les doy rápidamente un
poco de intuición visual acerca de por
qué esto tiene sentido
digamos que todo esto de aquí es mi
universo de resultados posibles entonces
la tercera parte de esto involucra a
monedas justas y las dos terceras partes
restantes son las monedas e injustas
recuerden tenía diez monedas injustas y
cinco monedas justas ahora bien nosotros
calculamos cuál es la probabilidad de
sacar cuatro de seis águilas dado que
estábamos en el universo justo por así
decirlo es decir calculamos como esta
sección cita de hoy y después calculamos
la probabilidad de obtener cuatro de
seis águilas dado que teníamos una
moneda injusta esto lo hicimos acá
y eso sería este cachito de aquí juntos
estas dos cosas me darían la
probabilidad de sacar cuatro de seis
águilas independientemente donde esté
parado y lo que el teorema beige me dijo
es que este chip o tito de aquí es
aproximadamente el 32.3 por ciento de
toda esta región que sería
la colección de eventos en los que saco
cuatro de seis águilas